hey 42 here humans have an uncanny
ability to make out shapes and faces in
the dark that aren't really there we do
this because our brain is deprived of
visual information to form a complete
picture because well it's dark so our
brain simply fills in the blanks without
telling us but the fact that we see
things in the dark that aren't really
there isn't the reason why we're so
afraid of the deep black of the night so
what is let's find out we are most
afraid of the dark when we're 4 to 6
years old
this fear tapers off by the time we
reach the age of 9 but it never truly
goes away the some adults are
considerably more afraid of the dark
than others but there's a part of all of
us that has some kind of apprehension
towards dark places in a poll 40 percent
of adults admitted to feeling scared
whilst walking around their own home in
the dark and 10 percent of adults are
too afraid of the dog to even get out of
bed when the lights aren't on a severe
fear of the dark is called Nyctophobia
if you're particularly afraid of the
dark you might think you could sleep
better with the lights on but you may
unwittingly be doing harm to your brain
a study at Ohio State University
discovered that sleeping with the lights
on damages your brain and increases the
likelihood of depression this is because
when it's dark our brain produces a
hormone called melatonin created in the
pineal gland melatonin helps to regulate
your body's sleep cycle when we don't
get enough sleep or we sleep in a room
that isn't entirely dark a melatonin
production is severely inhibited over
time a lack of melatonin can have
negative consequences on our body such
as your brain will age faster melatonin
deprivation speeds up the rate at which
your brain ages researchers think that
the elderly often have more trouble
sleeping because their brain doesn't
produces much military
as younger individuals which may also
contribute to the degradation of brain
function that some people suffer from
during old age a lack of melatonin can
also lead to a condition known as sad
short for seasonal affective disorder
sad is associated with sufferers of
depression the sufferers have sad have
an altered schedule for melatonin
release sad sufferers don't produce
melatonin until later on in their sleep
cycle meaning they get less melatonin
overall this can eventually lead to
worsening depression bipolar disorder
eating disorders and schizophrenia
melatonin deprivation has also been
linked to increases in blood pressure
and cancer rates health concerns aside
it's a damn good job that we are afraid
of the dark
and you shouldn't be ashamed of it
because believe it or not being scared
has its advantages especially when it's
dark humankind's fear of the darkness
stems from the days of early humanity
one before we evolved into modern humans
you see humans haven't always been at
the top of the food chain before the
advent of the hunter-gatherer and for
quite a while afterwards as humans were
the hunted ones our earliest human-like
ancestors first appeared around 7
million years ago although humans didn't
first step forth of the African
continent and into the Middle East until
1.75 million years ago that's a long
long time that humans had to defend
themselves against a myriad of natural
threats that they shared the African
plains with until we learnt to defend
ourselves humans were under constant
threat from animals such as lions hippos
crocodiles rhinos and snakes our early
human ancestors didn't stand a chance
against the pride of whales without
modern tools or shelter this problem was
made even worse during the night
predators used the pitch black of the
night to their advantage
a lonely defenseless human wandering the
plains of Africa didn't stand a chance
in the dark after all lions and other
predators can see in the dark consider
better than humans in fact 60% of lion
attacks in Tanzania between 1988 and
2009 were between the dark hours of 6:00
p.m. & 9:45 p.m. because of this humans
developed an instinctive fear of the
dark
that feeling of anxiousness that you get
when you're trekking through a dark
place is an ancient reaction that humans
have developed to warn us that dark
places are dangerous especially so
because in the dark we can't see where
we're going and we have no idea what
hostile creature might be coming towards
us the emotion that is anxiety is just a
tool that our body uses to get the job
done and that job is keeping us safe in
the dark over millions of years this
fear has been fine-tuned by both nature
and nurture to keep us safe from the
perils of the night you see it's not
just natural selection that enforces
this fear millions of years of children
seeing their parents become afraid when
they go out at night has helped to
reinforce and improve humankind's
ability to stay anxious and fearful of
the dark this ability may not be as
relevant nowadays because we no longer
have to contend with ferocious wild
animals on a daily basis but even in our
modern world the night still holds many
friends mostly of the human variety so
we should be very thankful for our fear
of the dark because it offers at least a
modicum of protection constantly
reminding us not to tread where danger
may look thanks for the view subscribe
for more 42
you